however dark the night however did one  powerful and by four o'clock the light  will always follow darkness keep going  the way you're going to end up as a bum  on the street  you train you fight harder than those  other guys and you win you can take it  you can make it you can do this look you  just gotta believe you can pop does ma  does  boy moment of pain is worth a lifetime  of glory  we're gonna die I'm not dying  I can use avenged  who is the Olympic athlete  don't look at me hello mother father  this is your Lois talking I'm now  interned in a Tokyo prisoner of war  Canada  I can't say this and it says about  America's not true this man must be top  news that each prison will teach him  this lesson  I used to think that I could do anything  but I was better than I am  if you can be through this I swear  authenticate my whole life  I can take it I can make it  the few drops that shared